let's find me a put it whatever these
guns I know where the I know where a
third gun is if you guys in here you
guys want these guns these guns
I'm not playing taking in my guns are
bigger than human hey Stacy
you impressed oh that's our sister isn't
it ah no no Oh cousin get it right I'm
sorry
you know duh I drank a lot of beads I'll
just be like I know I'm your cousin on
account of all the sex we had had yeah
with me right not him
I can't remember me do you mean it's
kinda hard to tell maybe can you bend
over forward I remember your ass I will
oh my crotch is right there good for you
oh yeah this is this is what I like are
you your ear oh my god wait mark wake up
again well you're not all the way they
give you jump look at Mark's jumping
sequence wait what am i doing I've no
idea okay no wait wait I don't you don't
you do it you do it that's a pretty
incredible ab work you got there way let
might look like this might look insanely
dirty no you just kind of rants in a bit
alright let's get out there and find
Bigfoot do we want one person to be our
trekker do we want to solve our trekking
bullet we should have one tracker cuz
there's some confusion sometimes of
switching between the two I don't have a
gun so I probably shouldn't be the truck
I'll go track mark all got back I'm
dedicated tracker this time I won't
screw it up layer guns and your rope all
right I got rope don't worry about it
all I know we used it on you last night
sister cousin sister cousin it's called
a sudden food that is I've forgotten
that that's it that's the term we use so
doesn't it way doesn't bobby-boy wait
why do you look so funny when you're
walking you walk it a little bit of a
Crouch like what the yeah you do too I
like a nerd all right salty our dragon
hard raggedly arm run go to the island
somewhat subtracting and I'm pretty sure
our missing persons are along the path
some ah the paths you say when Bob and I
were playing what is the path [ __ ] was
that
what would you hear I heard someone go
oh oh I didn't hear that if you hear
flies that's the sound of the bodies
being here well then why do you what the
[ __ ] did I just hear I don't know I
don't know there hey being a little out
of my mind is kind of exciting isn't it
Stacey good hey I mean well don't forget
these okay wait I wasn't even looking
enjoy the show
oh god that's good hey what about they
shoot you right in there Stacey wait
what actually kill me crazy what about
this I hear voices in my head pretty
good huh yeah like that that's good
reason alright so if I'm gonna pick the
winner who gets to bone me tonight
mm-hmm I'm gonna need to see some
sensitivity out of you guys okay all
right I enjoyed corndogs and walks on
the beach
mmm okay night Hey I think corndogs are
gross and I like walks on hard pavement
practical I like that here you want to
touch me oh hell yeah you know I do how
about this hmm
Wow slappy just slap it a little oh god
yeah yeah are you gonna sell this to hot
meat calm hell yeah
hope no Bigfoot come by and see this mmm
yeah what are we doing about Bigfoot or
something we do something about what it
is I heard a rustling oh I'm I'm not
hearing anything
oh I thought I heard a rustling that
hittin then again I hear voices in my
head apparently doesn't wait why are we
letting you lead us you don't seem done
in the past to try to find our missing
person what path there's no road here
well if you press the queue oh okay I
got you yeah you ready to press the
queue I've we're not definitive
sectioning doesn't wait sudden wait
don't don't press my cue or I guess
you're a buzzin a brother of rosin oh
sorry all right
should I track him brother brother Wade
yes you see ya ha ha now he's long gone
no he's way down the road there who
can't see anything with that oh yeah
there he goes since our mission was just
sort of a find Bigfoot is that like
mission accomplished
or you mean stop there just go home ok I
mean I feel pretty good about that hmm
Oh her harira khals appear to be
extending outward what are you talking
about don't look at her miracles are
like angle whoa hey you okay
are you all right okay you think she's
there armas also I mean what's wrong
with her Arbor she an alien we all log
that armor ooh
that's not right yeah it's not normal
she's not human huh oh so we shouldn't
feel bad no much Miley and lots of alien
scum is dead
Bigfoot is just protecting these woods
from [ __ ] alien invaders that's
what's happening here brother okay I'm
sick I'm picking up a trail I think he's
pooping he must live near here okay all
right follow me man doesn't smell good
totally didn't alien hmm how would you
possibly know an alien smells like you
[ __ ] llama yeah sessional he's an
alien
wait a minute oh I was wondering I
didn't have a twin brother two days ago
I stick at that yeah how do you just
randomly get a twin brother right yeah
that's a little weird
do you the hakka always been there
remember I told you I don't think that
you're true at all
this is a [ __ ] alien clone we got
around with us away well I'm not an
alien wait so do I get to choose which
one of you dies yeah I suppose that
seems fair
that's exciting well we'll just keep
looking for Bigfoot and I'll choose at
some point I'll let you know
okay all right Thank You Jess it's not
surefire way I can guarantee I'll prove
I'm not an alien
okay I'd like to see this all right all
right I promise I'm not an alien
Oh God sorry I thought you were going to
say that you were an alien that we just
that you want really whoa all right
follow up follow me moving on frozen
Wade I'm gonna get back this one's at
the trail I was following this was a
trail but what Zee trail okay the trail
we need to follow uh-huh
this way okay uh you guys have your meat
ready right why would we need that he if
he leads us to his alien ship shoot him
before he takes us on board okay all
right but what if I'm Harley and I'll
shoot you don't worry about it okay
thanks thank you I think either way I
probably both you but you know we'll get
there when we get there
that should be safe I don't even know if
I'm not an alien you know
yeah I can't after watching my gun turn
bloody I don't know yeah you know what
mark frozen mark even if you do turn out
to be an alien your candor and honesty
about your feelings oh [ __ ] what alien
[ __ ] did that which one of you [ __ ]
alien [ __ ] did that I don't know
under percent sure about that man I did
not ignore the lightning area that's a
cool fire tree this is how we're here oh
[ __ ] son everybody knew using your
you're not just leading us to a jump
scare again because I have a funny
feeling I remember something similar to
this happening before yeah I don't have
to go up on the tower this time I didn't
I did it last time on the rail it this
time
dude we do good hey [ __ ] I don't know
what happened I don't know what happen I
don't know what having it out early
again I ran over there hotshot get it to
replace all your I should I should
probably get it yes it's a blow on em oh
yeah all your jokes
bullets is your comedy shot ah don't
worry it's just joke bullet JT I felt
wounded just relax
uh it's joke old Hollywood a joke hole
come on yeah oh really giving it to you
right your joke oldest humor landing and
you're going all over lands right in my
you looking for a little joke up yeah
man yourself just a quick one maybe over
behind one of those trees when you'll
privacy here here I'll help you I got oh
well how did I not get him he's tracked
he's fresh hey he's not something is
tracked there's a tracking dart moving
away on my map oh I don't see it you
gotta follow it you're doing away we can
see it yeah I can't see he's going back
to his cave always going to the me
following you sunson Heidi I got hit and
I used to help back I did but I
continued you got hit too yes I was down
to like 25% health what does not eat oh
did I shoot you accidentally yeah look
guys I don't mean it is jumble come on
it's just a joke bullet man just calm
down it's a joke bullet yeah come on man
let's uh let's let's do this presence
we're we're with you all right here yeah
I tagged him again I still don't see the
tracking I can't see oh I see him
tracking down he's by the dead bodies
but I seem dragging him oh crackers once
until it wears off just so you know yeah
yeah I know it's just I never see it
before okay I passed a dead body on the
pass now at all times he was about now
alright let's do this he's coming right
at me I'm on the middle island facing
him and he's coming right at me
alright I see him I'm gonna get some
shots on him and then I'm gonna shoot my
flare [ __ ] you alright I've scared him
back away from the island he's going the
same way it was before
okay alright I'm still making my way
downtown I'm saying Sal you
whether cell north/northwest out of the
flowers going I'm going to reload the
trackers because I imagine it's probably
running out oh hell yeah I was coming up
he's coming back at me I'm in the swamp
right now he's coming back at the edge
of the swamp right at me looking trap
laid out here I see I see I see
oh I gotta go up he's going to the south
of me alright Oh coming towards me
coming towards me I'm gonna hit him with
another tracker job out he's got him I
think I'm alright we're tracking him we
are dominating this Bigfoot bro I'm
gonna try to get a few more pop shots
off yeah Oh nailed him in is noggin I
don't have a whole lot of ammo let's go
fortunately I've still got 31 shots left
so I got plenty I need so many bullets
after all those joke ones turns out that
just jokes man I don't know they're just
jokes
alright I'm on the path now behind him
to the west okay it looks like he
stopped going that way so I'm on about
the path right by the bridge so I'm
gonna I'm gonna lay a trap home we had
just we have this [ __ ] pinched
in so hard right now oh I see him oh
it's right by me
he's right by me he's right by me nope
oh yeah oh oh he ran past me he's
[ __ ] running away oh he ran past on
it pinched didn't work yeah I mean Jesus
I didn't get my flare off I tried to
flare them back towards you but I think
it's cuz they are day now he doesn't
really come at you at the day yeah he
was aggressive right now well we got it
out of like almost half yeah Wow
yeah that was a really good first hunt
well I'm back in at campers I'm back at
the camper oh hey what's up
we were equidistant away from each other
we're all alive
yeah and I had it out all right I'm
gonna show you guys a little blue you're
mine oh I thought it could be different
blow your loads okay well not what I was
painting weed uh-huh hey ah neat good
look around in here ah
most guys then Bob get another medicine
oh yeah I kind of do I'm sorry um
there's a guy with piercing Thor's
hammer hey guys nope Munoz Moulton
Bernard Bernard y'all hear y'all say
Jarrod's oh hey what's up a hammer that
I not the devil with feet that's not a
Bigfoot that's a big ear it's been our
units big it's his hands he's big hands
different and his right hand is a bit
more grabby than his active that's right
is Rusted that's Bigfoot frozen his
right-handed pulling the grocery Jay he
just picked up at the ith he's just
walking home just kidding he's got that
crazy head on doesn't mean he's a bad
guy so why do I see four come in here
makes two cave drawings and eat some
deer that is really the gravy Bigfoot
killed klore mm-hmm then what chance do
we stand maybe Bigfoot is mMmmm I'm not
I'm not as about I don't like it was
really just a stab in the dark there
yeah what I mean I thought tried to go
with you but I just couldn't
yeah I'm not on board with it either in
fact I feel like I feel like you've done
all of us a disservice for even opening
your mouth in the first place yeah I
mean we try and keep this forum open you
know and it's like all ideas are welcome
but like that it's within within reason
right like all right whatever
smartypants let's see what injuries why
did a little ever cave I'm not saying I
have theory I'm just saying put in some
effort yeah it's late it's like you're
gonna throw an idea out there and it's
ours the whole room like that's just not
productive
well at least I'm throwing ideas out of
you guys
no no no that means fine throwing ideas
but we had that rule because we didn't
know that there was such a bad
alternative we didn't think it was
possible isn't the thing on top of the
ground please place trap that I almost
tested
I warned you like five times you can't
complain when I warned you I don't know
right nicely placed even though you
warned me I still almost went to it yeah
go place dank I see okay here you fan
loving are you having like that
only say one word you have you having a
voice vocal problem yeah yeah yeah my
Pokemon stack dick who's that Pokemon
yeah yeah yeah take a moment I don't
know man
you come up with a joke I just came up
with it together you can get the
correction should be actually you should
be like kick this boner boner phone boat
boner boner boner boner please someone
draw all of these non pokemons because
that just needs to exist someone who can
draw please draw I can't draw I mean I
could drive whoa whoa Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
goddamn it
alright got him with a tracker I've only
got one tracking bullet left that scared
you so much
alright where'd he go going towards a
camper I can't believe he hasn't hit it
goddamn [ __ ] but he beeline right
for head we're just just walked through
the woods just vamping on dick Pokemon
and he's just [ __ ] comes out of
nowhere like an [ __ ] maybe he heard
the Collin was like dick dick dick dick
is a giant hand job really awesome he
watched up and he was just like I heard
someone talking about the human centric
nature of this world
profession the awkward position of
oppression that that puts us Bigfoot
people in it's refreshing to hear of
human with such an open
I just wanted to talk about social
issues I know why Bigfoot has a say
voices fat man uh what are the other
truck oh no I just like this world where
Bigfoot is like always surprised in the
middle of a sentence
honey I just don't feel feel that feels
fulfilled at work and I mean my boss is
oh man the leaves are really coming in
early
I can't believe help oh oh well I've got
two bullets he's got a lot of health
I've got a lot of bullets left
I'm at 31 shots 21 shots I don't have a
flare he seems I be wanting to come
after us maybe we should go to his cave
because he seems to be tonight he seems
to be hitting us hard maybe it might be
actually hold on let's go down here
there might be another Tower this little
dead-end path right here I'm not sure
what's over here oh I see what you mean
yeah you could really follow you
randomly it's gone oh oh oh god that's
loud [ __ ] ah I have a shitty tense
it's just that does not happen oh [ __ ]
wait where's my flare [ __ ] I meant it
with the flare under play way from
eyebrows hang on
oh my aim be true missed him oh no I got
him I got him
wait I see him he's mark I think he's
coming to engage us yeah yeah he's
coming maybe yeah he's coming he's
coming alright alright where are we
laying them right here right here line
it up right here this is where we fight
this oh my god because here he goes
until he comes hi you laid it on me
oh my god now ow Oh solo you solo oh
[ __ ] yeah I'm catching Bigfoot you doing
you actually big fun you got it what
yeah
we're not done yet we got to put him in
oh [ __ ] oh so I'm dragging him now are
you guys leat where am I going
back to the camper a little area this
way well we're actually really close to
this kind of convenient yeah you do all
the work Stan I got it don't worry don't
worry don't worry they're presents I got
this you're all muscly and whatnot but
did I didn't know it was all bloody yeah
we [ __ ] him up man
what happened I just hid closed door on
you I did not hit that I didn't do that
I'm not a joker oh yeah mother oh wow
what's up bro whoa hey someone whoa oh
look at that
it's going to light from like over there
yeah like that look at that that nasty
thumbnail that's so sick no no no I want
a good thumbnail you like a hurry oh I
like this like that see I get a rays of
light just yeah
God yeah that's a good some oh [ __ ] okay
well one of us is an alien we were doing
results oh yeah yeah we didn't we didn't
resolve this so um in all of our
adventures here which of us seemed more
human I'll put my gun away I'm pretty
confident wait I think I think we both
know whose alien okay yeah ha are you
with me yeah what I'm know why you're
reloading is very ominous oh yeah oh I
didn't even shoot back I'm pretty sure
you as a human must have been meeting
all you guys fell in exactly the same
position look at that he's not like we
live or spooning
so romantic except that we're dead
[Music]